[Musique]
le départ est donné pour ses 600 jeunes
venus participer à la journée nationale
du sport scolaire dans la forêt de
l'etang-salé bas on nous a dit que
c'était là la randonnée une marche de la
fraternité donc c'est très important je
pense ces valeurs là à inculquer aux
enfants
et comme j'ai eu une as randonnée voilà
ça nous faisait un peu voir un autre un
autre endroit que la savane à saint paul
se retrouver entre camarades
recall et tous pour une bonne marche au
programme quatre kilomètres de course ou
4 km de randonnée fraternelle des élèves
de primaires de collèges et de lycées
participent à cette journée placée sous
le signe de la fraternité du sport et de
la bonne humeur
mais dans le cas de conflit le sport
scolaire certaines valeurs qu'on veut
promouvoir la fraternité l'entr'aide
aussi les il ya le côté un peu
compétition puis à côté non compétition
voilà c'est un peu c'est des valeurs
qu'on défend dans le cadre de l'école on
se rend compte d'anciens amis qu'on voit
pas comme on n'est pas dans le même
collège
voilà ça va être dur
l'association run handi move a souhaité
aussi participé à cette journée grâce à
eux et à leurs jouets let trois jeunes
porteurs de handicap pourront vivre en
immersion
cette journée sportive c'est pour
changer leurs petites habitudes de l'ua
de rester chez eux ou à l'école
ben c'est on est là pour
faire découvrir les sentiers grâce à la
la joélette donc c'est un moment aussi
de
comme le disait le partage de rencontres
découvertes et pour changer leur petit
quotidien quoi une journée réussie pour
tous ces jeunes qui auront le temps de
cette action effacé toutes leurs
différences
[Musique]